Welcome to the Heavy Spoilers show I'm your
host Paul and Midnight Mass a Midnight Masterpiece.
The show is a 10 out of 10 for me and I feel
like starting a Fang Club for Mike Flanangan
as he's completely knocked it out the park
with his brand new horror show.
There's so much to sink your teeth into and
throughout this video we're gonna be breaking
down the plot, ending, the easter eggs and
all of the double meanings within it.
Full spoilers ahead so if you haven't seen
it then I suggest you get out of this video
in the neck of time.
If you enjoy it then please smash the thumbs
up button and don't forget to subscribe so
there isn't any bad blood between us.
With that out the way, thank you for clicking
this, now let's get into Midnight Mass!
Ok so Mike Flannagan has done a lot of projects
I've absolutely loved, Oculus, Doctor Sleep
and Haunting Of Hill House are all classics
in my eyes with the latter being one of my
favourite TV shows of all time.
When The Haunting Of Bly Manor was announced
I was extremely excited for it but unfortunately
I was a bit disappointed and found it to be
a show that was a retread of the aforementioned
series without any of the inginuity that made
it really stand out.
Flannagan has been planning the series for
over 10 years years and nods towards it appeared
as Easter Eggs in his previous projects.
Midnight Mass is the name of a book in both
Geralds Game and also Hush.
The blurb on the book even read: But the 512
souls on sleepy Crocket" and "church put
Riley face to face with a terrifying secret."
The eyes of the undead also look very similar
to the True Knot and it’s clear for Flanagan
that there’s a lot at STAKE here.
Now we open on the symbol of the ichthus which
was created after Christ multiplied fish and
loaves of breads in order to feed far more
people than they should have been able to.
This idea of symbol tied to Christianity is
quickly juxtaposed by the horrific crash that
kick starts the season and it subtly sets
up the idea that we will be facing several
themes such as religion which will be interlaced
with death.
In real life we've seen the horrors of what
religion can lead to in the likes of Jones
Town which similar to season ended up with
those indoctrinated sipping the Cool Aid after
they heard the promise of a better life.
It all begins with Riley a man who caused
a catastrophic car crash thanks to his drinking
which lead to the death of a young lady named
Tara Beth.
After serving four years in prison he's sentenced
to serve parole and he returns home to Crockett
Island, a backwards fishing community struggling
to stay relevant in an ever changing world.
Riley attempted to escape his life destined
to be a fisherman by entering the world of
tech, but alas, he would end up back from
whence he came.
He’s an atheist, having read every single
religious text from every religion Riley very
much sees life as a waste of time that sucks
worse than a Vampire.
This is what makes this show so layered and
no that's not a garlic pun...or is it onions.
Now usually religious horror is explored simply
through the eyes of Christianity, but in this,
many different view points are explored from
Riley’s Atheism.
There's a lot of examples such as a Sheriff's
unwavering belief in honour of his wife in
Islam and Bev, a Delores Umbridge-esque do
gooder who carries a hatred of anything that
isn’t Christian.
Riley is clearly wracked with guilt and over
the course of the series he must come to terms
with what he did, and his own mortality as
well as how his family and neighbours view
him.
He returns home to his family and tries to
adjust to life on the island but Tara Beth
watches over him, never letting him forget.
At night he dreams that he's out on a boat
in the middle of the ocean and we'll talk
about how the idea of life being but a dream
is paid off in this imagery later on.
Life on the island mainly focuses around the
church, St Patricks and the core faith of
each character is explored in great detail.
Spooks and jump scares are swapped for lengthy
monologues and discussions which are delivered
expertly.
Faith is key as the show rumbles on as we
meet each character such as Sheriff Hassan,
an NYPD veteran, pushed out due to racism.
Erin who wants to embrace religion and her
home once more as well as a mysterious new
priest called father Paul who arrives after
telling us that the last one fell gravely
ill.
Now as soon as I saw the large chest and cats
being eaten I said that it would be f**king
Vampires.
Those who've read Bram Stoker's Dracula will
know that the vampire arrived on the coast
of Whitby in England through a chest just
like this and if you've visited the fishing
village you'll know it's a similar sort of
set up to what we see in the show.
The Cathedral there looms over the entire
area much like the church in this and though
Flannagan isn't beating us over the head with
references it's clear he's giving nods to
the most famous Vampire story of all time.
Paul is later revealed to be Pruitt who traveled
on a religious pilgrimage but due to his dementia
he got lost and came across a Vampire.
Believing it was an angel he cried out for
help and the beast fed him his blood which
restored his health and healed him.
It's important to note that communion is very
much seen as drinking the blood of Christ
and again it's sort of like Poetry they rhyme.
Vampire of course need familiars in order
to travel out into the Sun and Pruitt very
much becomes the Angels.
Now upon his return to the island it’s hinted
that we are facing the end of days as a gigantic
storm rolls in.
The rain washes up the bodies of cats across
the beach which is reminiscent of the infamous
plagues and Riley is adamant that he had seen
Monsignor Pruit which is brushed away as being
shadows in the dark.
Paul or should I call him Pruitt starts mass,
explaining how the island will rise again
and over time he becomes a popular figure
on the island.
I love how this seems like just empty words
and faith at face value except he does have
a plan in that he wants to use the blood of
the angel and well to change the fortunes
of the island.
Many are down on their luck including Leeza
who was paralysed by the town drunk Joe who,
like Riley and Hasan is seen as an outsider.
The treatment of those in need but not seen
as socially acceptable like Joe by Bev shows
the nasty, selective side of religious people.
Though it's never confirmed, Bev ends up poisoning
Joe's Dog and it seems like she kills Paul
too which resurrects him.
We never get this for definite but he seems
to die much like the dog does with blood coming
out of his mouth and of course let me know
below if you disagree.
In the series we learn that if one dies whilst
the Angel's blood is within their system then
they'll rise up as a Vampire that wants to
feast on human flesh.
There's a lot of people confused over why
Paul could handle the light early on but at
this point he wasn't technically a vampire,
he just had the vampire's blood in his system.
Now Bev mentioned that the Bible speaks of
angels with burning skin in Revelation and
both she and Paul use this to justify their
actions throughout the show.
The pair cherry-pick scripture moving away
from the bibles altruistic messages and though
she seems to Paul despite when he changes
his mind at the end, she pulls out more scripture
that justifies her turning her back on him.
The idea of the angels in Midnight Mass comes
from the notion that the myth of vampires
and angels derives from an oral history that
evolved into the myth we know today.
When revealed to her what has happened and
what the angels do by feeding on blood, Sarah
surmises that the myths of these angels could
come from a blood disease that creates a drastic
need for iron.
Of course the idea of these angels is incredibly
similar to vampires but Christian ritual and
belief could be explained by these beings.
The sacrament asks worshippers to take wine
said to be the blood of Christ and he himself
died and came back three days later.
Sarah quite rightly explains this is indeed
where the Christian ritual could come from.
Sharing his blood would mean empowering and
curing people, explaining the miracles from
the Bible.
Pruitt has a plan for improving their life
by continuing to use the tainted angel blood
for the sacramental wine, regenerating the
cells of those that come to Church.
He intends to make everyone’s life better
and the healing properties of it allow Leeza
to walk again.
This Miracle brings more people to the Church
and thus it gives Paul a bigger flock to infect.
Hints start to show that something peculiar
is going on, as people start visibly healing.
Riley’s dad back mends itself, his wife
no longer needs glasses and she starts to
look young and Sarah’s Mother basically
does a Benjamin Button down that blouse you
Gilf.
Now It seems Flanagan has replaced hidden
ghosts for hidden heals and though it initally
seems like good news it also has adverse effects
in that it kills Erin's baby.
Atheism and faith in an era of miracles is
explored in great detail with Hassan struggling
to get his child to follow Islam, as Ali wants
to fit in and choose his faith, making this
a multilayered exploration of what it is to
believe.
Bev is vile towards the religion and only
becomes more and more emboldened as her idolisation
of Paul increases, someone she was dismissive
of at first.
After his death Paul starts jonesing hard
and he kills Joe before drinking his blood.
This happens after he points out the similarities
between Paul and a Young Pruitt and also pays
lip service to the affair that the latter
was apparently having with Sarah's mother.
Another hint towards an eventual reveal comes
when she said she thought she saw Sarah's
dads face at her bedroom window but this is
brushed away as being a side effect of her
demention.
Later on it's revealed that Paul is indeed
Sarah's father and we learn he was peering
into houses which was set up nicely in that
moment.
Bev involves other town members, namely Sturge
and Leeza's father and slowly everyone begins
to get their hands dirty in order to keep
up the sanctity of Church.
One night Riley on a chance encounter turns
up at the rec centre and sees Paul pouring
angel blood into the sacrament and Mr X, sorry
the angel who kills him and turns him into
a creature of the night.
If there was one core message I took away
from this show it is that not everyone is
as virtuous as they claim to be.
Paul explains to Riley what happened and urges
him to remember him by telling a story about
an altar boy who brought him a dying rat which
turns out to be Riley.
Pruitt lied to instill Riley’s faith leading
Riley to then have unrealistic expectations
growing up that he has now stepped away from.
There's an incredible scene with both Riley
and Erin in which they talk about what they
imagine death to be.
Because of his distrust of church the former
very much sees nothing at the end whereas
Erin who is grieving her baby imagines being
embraced by her family in the afterlife.
When Erin dies in the show she changes this
thinking and instead views herself as simply
a manifestation of the universe dreaming of
itself and what life would be like.
Einstein famously said that energy can neither
be created or destroyed and we are all simply
here and then gone back into the greater whole.
She summises The energy that happens when
her brain is firing must come from somewhere
and she sees this as simply being absorbed
back into the everything upon passing away.
Our consciousness came from seemingly nowhere
but we all have our own thougths and feelings
and when we cease to exist we will return
to whatever we were before.
It's a beautiful conversation and it somewhat
foreshadows Riley's death which comes not
long after.
Paul explains he wants to heal the community
but really he’s a self serving person who
has just accepted these awful things that
need to happen, citing scripture as a good
reason.
Paul intends for people to convert to being
an angel and be welcomed peacefully into this
new life but they will all very much be forced
to follow what he says.
Riley manages to break free and Paul lets
him, which just felt a bit misguided and naive
of Pruitt and eventually this constant faith
in him being correct about everything is what
leads to his downfall.
With Erin, Riley heads out onto the ocean
and explains that this is very reminiscent
of his dream.
He finally finds his purpose and Riley to
me is someone who had two options.
He could live for eternity as a self serving
vampire that would feed upon others to get
his wish or he could finally break free of
this and avoid hurting the ones that he loved.
Alcoholism, especially drunk driving is often
seen as a very self centred act and the character
doing this in the intro led to the death of
an innocent woman.
However it also hurt his family on top of
it and because of this he's lived a life of
misery.
Riley could easily feast upon Erin at this
point but instead he burns himself and gives
her the knowledge that he needs to take down
Pruitt and his followers.
This to me is why he's joined by the spirit
of Tara Beth at the end who has clearly forgiven
him because he learned from his mistakes.
Rather than being alone on the boat as he
was he has his greatest mistake forgiving
him and thus he can forgive himself as he
passes away...in a beautif...oh myyyyy goood
this is absolutel horrific.
Now Erin returns back to the island as the
night time mass is being prepared for easter
vigil.
This is one of the most popular times for
church attendance and thus he can recruit
more to the cause.
However Easter itself is also about the death
and rebirth of Christ which is a theme that
is used at the ceremony.
Erin plans to work with Sarah and her mother
to stop the converted however it ultimately
fails as they fall in line and head to the
church.
Fire is a very suitable idea and metaphor
to kill the angels and converted which is
used heavily later in the show as Sarah attempts
to burn down the church.
Fire in the bible is often used for purification
which fits in with these people who want to
wipe the island of those that don’t fall
in line.
At The church the attendees are offered up
a cup filled with Bev's poison and most of
them willingly end their lives in order to
be reborn.
However they're hungry for flesh and the undead
turn on the living which leads to a blood
bath.
Bev heads out into the night with the newly
converted and they cast judgement on all,
killing all of the islanders.
We see some of the best sequences in the show
as the rabid angels go around feeding and
burn everything to the ground believing that
revelations in upon them.
We witness Bev’s twisted view that God is
preparing his believers for the end of days
and that the conversion will help them in
the perpetual night.
Her truly awful nature is exposed as she turns
on Pruitt and won’t even feed on Hassan
believing his blood to be tainted.
The converted have their hubris ruined it
for themselves by burning most of the places
they could have hidden during the day and
we see Erin, Sarah and Hassan navigate to
the only hiding spots left to bring them down
in a blaze of glory.
It shows they are truly sinful and just like
Lucifer, their gift has been taken away damning
them to burn alive come dawn.
Pride and hubris is one of God's most hated
traits according to the Bible so he does truly
give and take away.
In the end For all his sins, Pruitt saw the
error of his ways and finally spoke to his
daughter without the burden of hiding the
truth.
He realized that he had lost his way and just
before this, the fundamental difference between
Bev and Pruitt was exposed.
She saw the church as being an ark and a base
to spread the conversion.
He explains it was about God and he wanted
to do right by his community except Bev has
taken it to the extreme and accuses him of
switching to ‘human things’ and not the
divine.
In reality, the hole he felt in his life has
been filled as he can now acknowledge his
secret sin.
He can finally leave the church, which he
wanted to all these years and end his life
on his terms with his family around him.
Now one question you might have is did the
angel die?
As Erin lays there dying she manages to cut
his wings as he feast on her neck.
Warren explains that the angel would need
to fly around 30 miles to beat the sun which
would be very difficult for it.
He’s unsure if the angel can make it the
distance but in the end we just don’t know.
This creature has of course survived for centuries
and I don’t think that you can count it
out either way.
It’s very much a schrodingers angel but
I do think that thematically we can say that
it’s gone too as it’s life was tied pretty
closely to the lives of islanders in the show.
However there’s always the possibility there
if Flannagan wants to do a sequel.
Now in the end we do have two survivors in
Warren and Leeza.
After gaining Chekovs sniper rifle they managed
to flee the island on a boat in order to wait
it out until dawn.
Both were virtuous with Warren abstaining
from drink and Leeza showing forgiveness to
Joe leading them to survive.
Leeza cannot walk or feel her legs which is
of course due to the angel blood running out
in her system.
Now Leeza may be back to square one but she
has rejected false prophets, something that
the bible has countless verses on.
In a twist of irony, Bev says similar verses
to Paul when he starts to doubt turning his
flock into vampires and over the suggestion
burning down the town is a bad idea.
Bev quotes Matthew 23:9 “And do not call
anyone on earth ‘father,’ for you have
one Father, and he is in heaven.”
Leeza and Warren’s escape could be looked
at as the rapture, escaping the damned Crockett
Island much like Christian’s say how the
believers will be saved and the rest left
to judgement.
The others had twisted their religion to justify
awful things and twisting the gift they were
given, showing that humans have not really
changed that much from the original sin.
However Riley preferred to end his eternal
life on his terms and could not abide by what
he would need to do, and sought redemption
in ending or trying to end what was going
to happen.
The survivors of Crockett sought peace in
the sun rise and look to wash themselves away
in the divine light of god.
The bible itself said in Luke 1:78-79: “Because
of the tender mercy of our God, whereby the
sunrise shall visit us from on high to give
light to those who sit in darkness and in
the shadow of death, to guide our feet into
the way of peace.”
The sunrise is a symbolic nature that it is
a new day and the sins of the past are washed
away.
We also see the ash of their bodies blow over
the boat and this is very symbolic of the
saying ‘ashes to ashes’ and ‘dust to
‘dust’ which of course pulls from the
bible.
As they die everyone on the island sings nearer
my god to thee and this has significance for
a number of reasons.
Firstly it contains lyrics about angels beckoning
those on Earth into Heaven and how they will
finally meet God.
However it was also the last song to be played
on the Titanic as it and it's passengers sunk
into the ocean to their deaths.
Though it should be seen as a tragic ending
for Leeza she has very much avoided the easy
road and though she is back to being paralysed
she is still alive, unlike all the others
who gave into sin and the temptation of a
better life.
Her defeating this tempation and breaking
away from the flock is what saves her life
in the end and it stands firm as a positive
message.
The series shows us that the road to hell
is paved with good intentions and though she
could have given in at any point due to pressure
from her parents, an authority figure and
her community, she didn’t and thus now gets
to live.
In the end it’s has a very powerful meaning
and overall the show was a stunning work of
acting, writing and the portrayal of a wide
range of beliefs.
This was merged into a layered and nuanced
view on the spectrum of belief and religion
that is a real page turner.
I know that phrasing doesn’t work here but
you know what I mean, it was an easy binge.
It’s something each viewer will take their
own meaning from, just like the good book.
While Midnight Mass is a wild departure from
The Haunting series and though some may take
a time to adjust to it, it is an absolutely
outstanding series that I can’t praise high
enough.
It’s rare that we give shows or films a
10/10
Now obviously I’d love to hear your thoughts
on the show and what you took from it as I
know a lot of people will have different views
on the series.
We're running a competition right now and
giving away 3 copies of the Zack Snyder DC
Trilogy on the 30th Of September.
All you have to do to be in with a chance
of winning is like the video, make sure you
subscribe with notifications on and drop a
comment below with your thoughts on the episode.
We pick the comments at random at the end
of the month and the winners of the last one
are on screen right now so message me @heavySpoilers
if that's you.
If you want something else to watch then make
sure you check out our breakdown of Squid
Game which will be linked on screen right
now.
That’s another amazing Netflix series you
should check out so hopefully I see you there
right after this.
With that out the way thank you for sitting
through the video, I’ve been Paul and I’ll
see you next time.
Take care, Peace